yeah yeah
forty you don't review movies fifty
while your face looks weird when you
smile like just overthrowing at random
insults 60 betrayed everything does good
about the musical 78 betrayed everything
that was good about the book somebody
actually read the book and woke up there
okay and you want me to be looking for
I'm gonna be looking at you okay right
as soon as I say that you turn to me you
know you shout you're 15 40 yeah 40 you
you turn in look at me I know no I shall
go yes
yeah Oh Tamra I think we may still need
you here yeah 40 you don't even review
movies 50 you're faceless we're gonna
smile I just thought we were throwing at
random insults 60 it's a betrayal of
everything that the Broadway show stood
for 70 you betrayed everything that was
good about the book someone actually
read the book 40 yeah what's my line no
timeouts right you don't review any of
these yes that's it okay I'll be all
right boy you don't review movies 50
your face looks weird when you smile I
just thought we were throwing up random
insults 16 it's a betrayal of everything
that the musical stood for 70 you
betrayed everything that was good about
the book
someone actually read the book perfect
okay che mi raker yeah should be good
okay cuz I cuz I'm in frame is my head's
in frames yeah a little bit yeah okay
forty doing the review movies fifty your
faceless we were you smile I just
stopped throwing up random insults sixty
if betrayed everything that musical
stood for seven get you betrayed
everything that was good about the book
someone actually read the book good
forty it piece of shit forty you don't
even reviewed fifty your face looks
weird when you smile I just thought we
were throwing out random insults sixty
it's but c60 it betrayed everything that
I and I laughed a bit you spit on my
face oh sorry
sixty I betrayed everything that the
movies did me just goes to them sixty I
betrayed everything that the musical
stood for seventy and portrayed
everything that was good about the book
I try that again
yeah uh get you to back here again my
secret assassin oh she's my assassin
form take foot warm up roses just
terrify people hopefully it'll scare
them to death okay so we're going to be
looking at each other and we just turn
look at Malcolm and I'll just give you
go be one two three we go yeah and then
we will go over this way cuz Tim's going
to be talking and that's you see yeah
maybe we can find a way to review it
despite all that okay
looking angry to each other as soon as I
say action action one two well maybe we
can find a way to review it despite all
that good oh yeah I'll be a little
louder on this one look at your well
maybe we can find a way to review it
despite all that I'm just gonna get a
shot in the wall for absolutely no
reason
whoa whoa oh my god I've got totally
insane
ha ha ha ha ha Oh which I haven't
written into the scripture ha ha ok
talking about Rainbow Brite that's right
it's when they steal the color okay
yeah that's sorry it's the charka it's
just so me you're the target suddenly I
am the chart again thank you
products oh yeah should tell us
something in charka voice oh yeah I see
that
okay I am going to say things about
optioning sort of for you message you
get your own action number three three
three a DVD in pieces some of you may
recall a movie sorry
a strange film some of you may recall
the strange film of the Phantom of the
Opera some of you may recall the strange
number three three three DVD in pieces
some of you may recall the strange film
of the Phantom of the Opera
great uh I think ready and action
number three three three I DVD in pieces
some of you may recall a strange film of
the Phantom of the Opera
beautiful oh so silky smooth did you
wash our shooting the next scene ever
like these only five melodies we'll do
it over from the cupcake sorry I'm
impressed you got all those down oh are
you sure you sure hey you the killer
ha so sad emo kind and on D I couldn't
do that to him we have the once if you
do one like like say the light a Jeter
never got it okay hey ready and action
ah sweet cheeks your back
oh yeah I know I'm fine you know don't
bother sending out a search party it was
a little over my line uh uh sweet cheeks
your back oh yeah I'm fine you know
don't bother sending out a search party
for me I wouldn't but we've been very
busy here you know like a phone call or
one of those milk cartons oh man if we
were all singing this one song it was so
funny maybe an Amber Alert everyone was
singing over each other oh I'm sorry
you want us to know if I the fleets of
the person who kidnapped you I couldn't
do that to him look evidence
so did you want to bury the biter I said
I couldn't do that to him do that one
more time to do a 3-2 yeah okay can I do
that I couldn't do the whiplash one more
time to you sure I don't feel it how sad
enough can you read the proceeding line
sure uh I'm sorry
you want us to notify the police of the
person who kidnapped you I couldn't do
that to him okay what else
so did you want to grab a body turn I
said I couldn't do that to him nice
Susu Susu this is and I wear so much red
lips too
or no yeah and I got to the butler
gerrae
ah get your minds to attorney to display
you worse I see this from the movie oh
yeah like every other leader from 300 oh
yeah The Phantom angelic voiced phantom
who can't say so you know especially
near the end you know he's like you know
where are the rich it's like this is the
choice this is the point of no return
something like that yeah all right huh
and y'all so funny is you thinking can
you think that's exaggerated that's
exactly how he said out of it he's going
wow it's like every single line he's
like trying to get his sound audible
through a large body of water remember
that we might want but neither that's
incredible the next is uh phantom of the
sparked um yeah
the next is you and me um shooting the
phantom down on his love like that
that's how you do this number what
happened that's all we need yeah well I
feel what we're gonna do front ran
through the lead in first which is you
know which is
it's 200 so you need me on camera yes oh
hey cool wasn't your beer doing me or
Tamra first jackets every night here
whatever wonder you want
I mean convenience your presence my
rebuttal gets International Women's Day
ah are you - suppose that my mind this
is it
oh yes back yes a little bit oh no
you're looking at a grave basket it's
like this symbolic I think that your
culture Somali sanitary yeah um let's
actually have a I'm gonna have you
looking that way and down like a grave
and have your arms your hands like that
yeah
all you're gonna do is look a little
hold it
sorry sorry sorry sorry airport where's
my air horn and what you're going to do
you're going to act like hyper is right
here okay so this is after you turn your
head and you say oh nothing I just I was
just remarking on something very close
to me and how watching it fade is almost
like losing a friend good read on that
do you stand about right here breakfast
is okay do you need me to do the head
turn no you're a ranger I think you're
ready and okay oh nothing just from them
about my so sorry it's based on the
first step just remarking on see just
remarking on something very close to me
you have watching a Vegas like losing a
friend yes nothing just remarking on
something very close to me how losing is
almost like losing a friend watching a
face nothing just we're working on
something pretty close to me and how
watching it fade is kind of like losing
a friend perfect one more just for
sitting yeah I'm so sad about a book
yeah don't take my word you're gonna be
kinda same position she was where you're
looking this way and looking down you
crush me man
I might blow that out just in case
that's a me I'm thinking like I'm just
to be a face
actually did scare me no file which is
where we are
yes scores and fairytale and that's the
being hard I'm going to be tracking it I
so so you can go ahead but CP other
stuff and it will keep you nice and cool
yeah no was doing
oh yeah you gotta angle it oh that's it
yeah that's the thing that steady no
explanation and then we get a copyrights
right
things ahead okay head down looking more
camera
yeah try your best to kind of keep your
head back up again
so he explained to the camera the week
like hey oh yeah it's just very clumpy
been used a lot of ways when we use them
so much just get really the Chester a
bum wig oh just nasty as you think okay
this is awesome
for anyone who thinks that was it
singing hmm hmm don't doubt
yeah
ah and mr. dramatic oh there it is I'm
just doing that's the aftermath right
it's one of your biggest fans
no this is Arnold Palmer life it does
say find a tombstone yeah you're gonna
sort of like you know you're gonna be
here you're just gonna sort of peek out
like you know and then back and I will
get the other side of the tombstone
why is she I forgot what she's hiding my
own tombstone
well because when everything's happy
when the Phantom comes in like you she's
just she does one get the way so she
hides and she hears okay what's going on
still she's one ago yeah Crawford I know
but not too much you know I don't know
he'll think not for a while what's like
you become very emotional again like
down maybe on 1d all right improv
exercise hammer you'll play the part of
a lizard yes
I got like a leave you did you say woo
it is very reptilian like yeah you can
stay down there but just like when you
do just guess what's in here oh okay and
now you can just get down
yo and action good I'll do no okay ah
this link is together and we can great
halogen over and edge this is a lot more
like I like a hull really in great and
will just somebody limiter grifone sis
it just she just needs a dial if it up
oh oh oh my oh my phone just buzzed it
mm phone someone texting me okay yeah
you're gonna be on the other side you're
just gonna come back you just you're
dialing dialing two numbers good
very easy number to remember yes Benny 2
2 2 2 2 2 2
that you used to call me on my hell
phone that's where he was last time we
heard alone
know what Benny he doesn't live there
yeah just vacation affair yeah yeah
Benny he is everywhere he is nowhere
yeah in fact he might be behind the
camera right now
oh wait that's someone else yeah I'm the
and as an SEM you cover all magazines uh
paper skills you can care of a big
contagious I'm sorry
speakin it's the empathetic yawn that's
what it's called
hey bring that is a beastly wig I think
it came alive at one point like one on
its own adventure okay deal Brandon it
was crawling did you oh my god what it
was just the hyper one with the glasses
right now make no sound sorry gadget
lasts for a bit I need you in the Viper
outfit here I'm sorry
oh no that's right hyper up yeah that's
exactly what I was thinking
you know you don't see okay it's like
yoga yes actually
the worst lines ever written in music
history
no there's so much worse than that I'm
sorry that one is really bad
no my virgin and what is it that we met
you off wrote Oh written like yeah
you're just excuse me about you wrote a
awful lyric that you couldn't get out
I mean written looks fun
sounds like we did that just tomato
right I was all right so I guess we're
just waiting for oh and then uh so for
um address for Tamra for the hyper
Carlotta thing and stuff I mean were we
just gonna do the bell Tristan I think
so okay
what does what yeah house of the
beginning
what the fuck it's a bunch of crap Amin
what the fuck Turkish shut your trap
under all the joke and of all the cash
on to Mexico rui on crack have you see
these latest texts oh dear Christ what
Evers next cuz I'm him
yeah oh you just got a shot we got it
right yeah and even more zoom and ugh
but not me it's Tamron wild happy
International Women's Day
let me know when y'all ready oh there's
Tim yeah yeah Tamara's record in how the
magic happens to this is the magic came
right here give it to us magic on the
wings of a jesus d-o-d matter right
woman yeah I was being which he's gonna
do the full house one for us beautiful
level yes I'll go ahead stand up again
magnify the exposure always that should
be good okay do that all right pretty
bad
yep and
what the fuck it's a bunch of crap Amin
what the fuck Turkish shut your trap
don't draw the joke of all the cash into
Mexico are you high on crack have you
seen this place text told you price
whatever net
what the fuck it's a bunch of traveling
what the fuck Turkish on your trap under
all the dough of all the cash of Mexico
are you high on crack have you seen
these the latest text Oh deer cries
whatever's next
I realize this is cuz you guys changed
the lyrics it says these are both signed
F G he doesn't have the other phone cuz
they were two tax sent in the original
so do you want me to just hand him did
you wanna be you know what I'm looking
at I read the text as well do that these
are both signed up G
cuz I read it over there as well so do
that okay yes yeah okay so these are
both side you okay yeah I can even come
to my reaction I'll be good okay let's
try one hey you're all ready yes yes
hello
and so what breaker buggy will be
rubbing on what's from tumescent factory
who would have the balls to send this
someone would rush Snyder's drain these
are both side of G the hell is he
he's a pretty sleepy arduous I guess the
secatur like a failure to assemble
Prabhu
she stood oh and sober breaker monkey
will be rubbing off what's from two
message back who would have the balls to
send this summon with rush night's rain
he's a bull side of Jing the hell is he
and a goat
he's a predatory major - in service
dedicated like a Vader's news ever
she gotta get two more over there yes
there you go how's that dress doing
Tamra no that's a look at at iris look
she's been assaulted or so that's not
right
get that one of those other than the
other leggings yeah it just look yeah
yeah there you go I gonna hang it off
yeah I feel like this is a very special
episode of like SVU baby to overdo it
but you can even be looking at like
pretend these are chats
Oh Piper finger oh you can't leave you
score high in the 12 to 29 Democratic
plus a subset of 65 or 70 year olds oh
here I'm leaving and use your supposed
to challenge I kind of made you happy oh
oh oh I got this is like yes oh yeah
that is an old binder okay everybody
ready yes good and action the only
reason why I even agreed to play
Carlotta is because I thought we were
going to get a love scene Carlotta is
the jealous singer of Christine she
doesn't have a lot see why else would
you cast me as the ego centric prima
donna character um oh oh hi professor oh
you can't leave you score high in the 12
to 20 on a democratic plus with a subset
of 65 to 70 year olds no no critic you
have to move easily yeah we just sang a
song about it
hi Bert what's this all about I thought
we were over yeah but it's hard to let
things die well start now
if you don't mind I'm really busy pay no
heed to him here I'll surely some yes
yes yes
I affirm these anime I agree good clap
stop you guys throw the fight Jim if you
want to stay you can if you're tired I
need to sleep you can do that too it's
completely up to you oh yeah but now
you're on camera it's like she later
fucker and that was Jim's final day it's
not ah hello no no we're behind the
scenes stuff I mean yes we're behind the
scenes stop tell us something that the
lonely eyes wouldn't know about you uh
maybe they you know um I Drive a
Volkswagen Claire don't care about the
lies they told about the environment
it's got a seat warmer hey you of them
is too awesome
I'm currently opened on Wow clearly I'm
a runner at the runs
yeah is that even your real name
so Megan feels like we're like right I'm
just so happy that it's finally coming
to a wrap your your part is yes all
right we still have turnout
yeah well done yet about although it's
going free fast yeah weird again
yeah that our you would locked up for
one line really went fast be like a what
was that we had two lines with hyper and
he's like what for some reason I blocked
out an hour for that very little sleep
this way so I'm gonna make a mistake or
two Wow our Sora line yeah here no
wonder we're always ahead of time hyper
grandma you should have seen how she
look like when she got here earlier
today this is what working she looked
beautiful
there we go until then oh you all know
the scary thing that's still the belle
dress wow that's an evolution nice well
this is yes me signing off